the parent company of the Mandalay Bay
Hotel in Vegas has now released the
videos of Steven paddock and those days
before the deadliest mass shooting in US
history now they show him standing close
to the bellhops as they delivered
numerous bags full of whoa we know what
they were now weapons and ammunition
well as the prime suspect in the October
shootings paddocks motive remains a
mystery as he apparently killed himself
rather than be captured but let's ask
the experts what the videos might reveal
Randy Sutton is a retired la Las Vegas
excuse me police officer and Aaron Cohen
is a security and Counter Terrorist
great to see both of you
Randy let's start with you and I want to
go piece by piece if we could through
the video because I think it's really
important for us to get very specific in
advance the analysis here as we do it
now first we're watching Steven paddock
checking in which is the video we've
been calling for for months at the
Mandalay Bay front desk let's watch it
yeah we can yeah so we can see him
checking in you guys have both watched
it what should we be looking for here
well what we're seeing here is you know
he's a he's a high roller he's a he's a
heavy gambler and he's checking into the
VIP desk which affording him he doesn't
have to stand in line like other people
so it's a very expedited process and
since they know him very well
he's just putting his his name in there
getting there all the credit card uh
stuff situated and he's and he's on his
way and let's let's move on to the next
piece of video and this is with the
bellboy and all the luggage he's a big
bags and he's being he's bending over to
fix his pants now why is that in any way
relevant Aaron
well he's shifted first of all he takes
the back entrance which the hotel claims
is not uncommon taking a service
elevator I've never brought bags into a
hotel in Vegas and gone through the
service elevator so obviously that's an
advantage in it pardon me while I look
at the footage as I'm explaining that's
going on here there's a second long
delay his body language his hands in his
pocket his legs across which means he's
trying to block
any type of nervousness he's got one
hand up right now he's in he's in it
just looks like he's generally
uncomfortable right now it's fidgeting
with his face he's touching his face
that's not uncommon with it with a
behavioural red flag with somebody who's
trying to cover something and again he's
overly scratching his head right now as
I'm looking at the footage so all of
these this is nonverbal communicating
Laurel which is which is what I'm
trained in specifically in Israel for
boarding flights in Israel to go to
Israel and this type of behavior you
can't lie with nonverbal communicating
and so what I'm seeing right now with
somebody who's covering intensely and
he's fidgeting is moving and shuffling
he's turning is let's go let's get the
cart moving
he's just generally uncomfortable the
shirt is untucked also there could be a
weapon on his pants who knows Randy I
want to ask you about this the timeline
that apparently is still not agreed to
there's no timeline that all authorities
seem to say yes this is how it happened
there's a lot of still swirling
conspiracy theories about what happened
in Vegas right it still seems really
weird to me I mean that's just my you
know you have a gut instinct about
something the guy who was not really
that he was known by authorities he
thought he had a criminal history but
then there wasn't a criminal history
it's there's a learning lot there's a
lot of play here but you know what we
saw today is very interesting in a
couple different ways though Laura you
know this is the first time that we have
been we've been given the access to
actually see him engaged in his daily
activities while he was staying at the
hotel now you got to ask yourself what's
the timing why is this happening now and
I think it's very interesting that that
the hotel finally decided to give up
this footage to a major news source and
what's the reason for that is it because
there is so much there's so much in play
here with people you know espousing
conspiracy theories that finally if you
look at this there's finally something
that that were we can actually as you
know being interested in this subject
we're finally getting to see something
here well and are we seeing something
Erin that informed
that's the kind of guy he is or
motivation we're not getting to any of
that he's a guy who sat in front of a in
front of a you know a slot machine for
hours and hours and hours and brought
these heavy bags in a service elevator a
VIP check-in swaying back and forth we
have the extra video video here where we
see him swing back and forth with the
bellboy as well which we're gonna see it
see him there yeah there it is
but still there's waste we know nothing
about this guy the biggest mass shooting
in US history and we know still very
very little about him Aaron that's right
and that's why I'm jumping all over you
look at him right now he's got the hands
in this pocket it's a very awkward
shuffle he's doing he's nervous he's
projecting nervousness
he's flagging like crazy Lauren these
are the red flags that we look for again
in Israel the difference between how we
do security and how the rest of the
world does security is that we know that
you can spot the behavior of a murderer
before he commits the act of murder it's
just as red flagged as it is afterwards
so he's flagging like crazy
and it's not the mandala based fault
they're not trained in this no one here
in this country is really trained to do
this except for certain aspects of the
FBI for their profiling and in certain
portions of Border Patrol which is
getting better but we don't know
anything about this guy it's a complete
mystery
I understand all the conspiracy to go to
Randy's piece and I've known Randy for a
while he's like Randy is very very smart
and knows Vegas better than anybody
knows how hotels are I think they're
obviously the hotel put out the the
video to cover their butts they want to
get it out there and say look exactly we
can't the hotels basically to me what
it's saying is guys we look at the
evidence here you look at this guy and
you can see just as we can that he's
just a normal guy he's gambling he's
checking in but once you start cracking
this thing open its Laura it's how do we
use this video and this is a body image
the next to prevent it from happening
yeah what do you what do you think about
the pathology that hasn't been addressed
here at all the pathology of a heavy
gambler a degenerate gambler if you will
someone they can spend eight hours at a
time literally spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars at a sitting
how do
think that that plays into the the
factors here because I think that
there's something here it's being missed
what do you think's being missed
that's my Israeli answer what are you
what are you where you going where you
leaning I think I think that the
pathology of the degenerate gambler it
plays a role in in the way we should be
looking at this man as a suspect they're
socially isolated they're they sit in
front of a machine you could say that
about a lot of people sit in front of
video games but not everybody who sits
in front of a machine we got we got blue
hair people all over Vegas tonight sit
in front of machines you know like you
guys seen the but they don't even have
candle anymore they just think this is
gonna come down Laura I think what this
is going to come down to is the tools
have already been developed to be able
to predict violence through looking at
behavior and the question is is when are
we going to take the model that already
works and how do we disperse it to these
mega hotels and casinos and to all these
other mega infrastructure places like
the massive mall and in Minnesota and
really and really start looking and
cranny behavioral detection programs
because really you can't throw more
security guards at this problem you have
to train the guards and as soon as we
start taking the profession more
seriously then I think we're gonna start
having it takes money it takes training
and it takes a you know you can't be
totally correct and we're all poets are
cracked and I would have you both on
radio right now it doesn't get any more
politically correct one of the heart of
political correctness here absolutely